[Musique]
en 1978 ou qu'on se trouve résonner les
chansons de la comédie musicale succès
grise
c'est le premier film qu'a vu geneviève
borne au cinéma geneviève toi tu mmorpg
louise j'adore j'adore gries ce film que
j'ai vu le plus souvent dans ma vie tu
crèves regarder encore monsieur semaine
je le regarde tout le temps
c'est un film qui me rend joyeuse gries
ce sont des chansons qui nous restent en
tête des chorégraphies mille fois imité
une belle histoire d'amour entre la
douce cindy hocine interprété par paul y
vienne est une jeune et le rebelle
dennis ou co incarné par un john
travolta au sommet de sa gloire
après le succès de saturday night fever
[Musique]
c'est vraiment la naissance d'un couple
mythique
c'est vraiment un des couples les plus
marquants de l'histoire du cinéma et de
la musique leur façon de danser leur
façon de chanter ensemble leur voix
ensemble sont tellement belles ils sont
beaux à l'écran et on y croit on y croit
à leur histoire d'amour complètement
[Musique]
après avoir été un succès sur bois doubs
et au début des années 70 la comédie
musicale est adapté pour le cinéma à
hollywood
pour l'occasion quatre nouvelles
chansons dont la pièce glisse sont
ajoutés à la trame sonore du film pour
s'assurer des passages radio une grande
chanson est associé un film ça met du
monde dans les salles de cinéma parce
que c'est de la pub
alors oui c'était des succès qui se
colle un pea plus la gamme qui ont
fabrice c'est là même qui avait fait sa
tambouille févr je pense que c'est la
formule un peu la chanson grise a été
composée par barry gibb des bee gees et
interprété par frankie valli qui avait
connu le succès avec le groupe de
fossiles la chanson bruit cela s'est
joué à l'endrevié d'internet et jouait
dans les jouets à la radio tout un
partout partout la recette du succès de
glisse des vedettes des chorégraphies
des tubes et de la nostalgie car
l'action se déroule dans les années 50
il est toujours comme un des générations
qui s'accrochent aux générations
précédentes avec le label aux côtés
brillantine de windsor qu'on recourt
là-dedans fait que c'est pour ça que ça
a obtenu un si grand succès ni les
paroles parlent beaucoup de cet espoir
qui habitent les jeunes qui en termine
le second d'un raté de mettre de côté
les conventions et de croire en nous et
de croire que tout est possible qu'on
peut atteindre nos rêves c'est vraiment
sa gries alors c'est vraiment une
chanson d'espoir sont
es tu
le service de streaming par amende plus
récemment annoncé avoir commandé gries
rice de pink ladies un antépisode de la
comédie musicale culte de 1978 dont la
date de sortie n'est pas encore connue
restera à voir si les aides seront aussi
nombreux et si la nostalgie fait
toujours recette
[Applaudissements]
ici n'est bien alexandre chartier radio
canada montréal